si de esas víctimas mortales 13 hay que
lamentar las aquí en nueva york entre
ellas una niña de tan sólo dos años y
desgraciadamente esa cifra total podría
seguir aumentando a medida que avanzan
las labores de rescate porque todavía
hay mucha gente atrapada en vehículos y
en casas hay hogares que se han
convertido en auténticas trampas
mortales porque el agua entraba en ellas
y era más peligroso quedarte quedarse
dentro que salir los servicios de
emergencia trabajan todavía a estas
horas a contrarreloj en una tarea que no
es nada fácil porque hay todavía cientos
de carreteras cortadas solamente en
pensilvania más de 380 muchas de ellas
vías principales se han convertido en
auténticos ríos y para circular por
ellas hay que hacerlo con barcas esto
está dificultando las labores de
socorrer a las personas que se han
quedado atrapadas hay más de 150 mil
clientes sin suministro eléctrico y las
empresas ya han dicho que tardarán en
restablecer la energía porque los
destrozos son muchos y muy cuantiosos no
se veía una tormenta así desde hacía
muchos años en todo este área
tri-estatal
nueva york pensilvania y nueva yersey la
gobernadora de nueva york la recién
estrenada gobernadora de nueva york hoy
decía que se trata de inundaciones
históricas y que hablar de algo sin
precedentes es quedarse corto ha pedido
ayuda al presidente joe biden que hoy
mismo en una declaración ante la nación
ha dicho que aportará todo el apoyo
federal que sea necesario y ha dicho que
ahora mismo se están centrando en cuatro
áreas una restablecer el suministro
eléctrico a restablecer el suministro de
gasolina también que en sitios como
luisiana empiezan ya a escasear a ayudar
y apoyar económicamente a las personas
afectadas a los pequeños negocios y dar
cobijo para esta noche y para las
siguientes a todas aquellas personas que
lo necesiten si algo en algo han
coincidido todos los gobiernos
nacionales y locales que hemos podido
escucharlo a lo largo del día de hoy es
que el cambio climático está detrás de
estos terribles hechos y que es algo
cada vez más amenazante y más común